returning back to the topic of vectors
um this is a question which wasn't done
as well as we would have hoped because
actually the working for it is quite
straightforward um but several students
just kind of missed a crucial part of
this or uh saw the part of this question
that was missed but didn't know how to
use it so let's have a look together
consider the line r equals
and here's your position 2 1 3 plus
lambda of 0 negative 1 3 there's the
direction determine the vector equation
of a line which passes through this
point 2 3 1
which is perpendicular to the line above
and parallel to the yz plane okay so
let's just stop for a moment and try and
understand what's going on
what we've been given is a particular
line
and because we're in three dimensions we
really need to use vectors to state the
equations of these lines because it
captures all the components which is it
captures all the components that we're
looking for x y and z
this one equation is equivalent to three
parametric equations one for x one for y
and one for z
now we wanna find a new line or the
equation of a new line that passes
through some other point two three one
and we wanted to have these
characteristics it's perpendicular to
this line now i want you to remember if
you're trying to be perpendicular this
is a question of direction right so when
you're talking about perpendicularity
here or orthogonality as it turns out
you really need to pay attention to this
direction vector up here right you want
some uh
new direction vector which when you you
know compare these two you should find
that they are right angles and hopefully
you're remembering the piece of
knowledge that will help you here is
that uh when you take the dot product of
two vectors that are perpendicular
you should get a dot product of zero
right now that's that's all fine most
people are pretty good at that however
it's this last piece that most people
completely missed this new vector that
we're about to find out not only is it
perpendicular to line r
it's also said that it's parallel to the
y z plane now why is this important the
answer is if you think about any given
vector in three dimensions so i'm just
going to use my pencil as an example of
a vector whichever way it is facing
there are actually infinitely many
vectors that are perpendicular to this
vector that pass through a particular
point okay let's just suppose like the
middle of my pencil was the particular
point that we were interested in and i
said hey can you find another
another vector the equation of another
vector that passes through this point
and is perpendicular the answer is you
can find infinitely many if i pick up
another pen
if you just imagine it like this right
said in the middle there right so here
is a vector that's perpendicular right
but if i say well hold on a second uh
let's twist it around this is another
vector it's also perpendicular and so is
this one and so is this one and i can
just go around infinitely many times
right there's no reason why i have to
like be locked into one or the other now
that's why this last piece of
information is so important that it is
parallel to the y z plane so if you can
imagine like the y z plane is like
somewhere off to here right well this
vector that i'm holding right now is no
longer parallel to the yz plane it's
going to collide straight with it
if i sort of angle it a little bit
it is still
i don't have enough fingers
if i get that one right there it's still
perpendicular to my original vector
still passes through my special point in
the middle but if my
yz plane is here right even though i
don't directly collide with it straight
away eventually this vector is going to
go and it's going to collide back where
i position that right so there is only a
single vector like this i guess pointing
right at you that's going to be parallel
to this plane and also perpendicular to
the original vector that i specified so
that's why you need that piece of
information and very few students um or
disappointingly few students knew how to
use it so let me try and illustrate to
you how i would do it
this is part b
so how does our working actually play
out
well the first thing that i want to say
is okay here's the original vector or
yep the original line i should say
original line
which is r equals
and it was given to us as 2 1 3 plus
lambda of 0 negative 1
3. so there's the original line right
now the new line needs to pass through 2
3 1 and so that the first easy thing to
say is oh okay
2 3 1 is going to be the position right
so i can say the new line
is going to have to be r equals
and i'm going to get onto an easy way to
get onto the point 231 is just to make
that my position vector
2 3 one now i then have to work out the
direction vector and this is the tricky
part right now normally i would say oh
let's just pick some arbitrary
coefficients here pop them in and see
what happens right like i could call
them a b and c however if i look back at
the question and this piece of
information that everyone sort of missed
a little bit right if you have a look
and see
that this is parallel to the y z plane
parallel to the y z plane what that
means is the x component has to be zero
let me say that again right if you're
parallel to the y z plane your x
component has to be zero an easy way to
compare that is just to think back to
two dimensions right so if i were to
draw for you here is uh you know a good
old cartesian plane
and i said to you oh okay what does a um
what does an equation that is or a line
rather that's parallel to the x-axis
what does it look like right well if
you've got something that's parallel to
the x axis like so
it's going to be y equals something or
other right
there's no x component in that line
because as soon as you introduce some x
component you're no longer going to be
like if it was you know
y equals i should say like this is some
constant like c
as soon as you introduce some x
component like x plus one or x plus c or
whatever right you're now at an angle so
you're going to go back and collide with
the x axis so my point here is that you
can't have this x component in there
right so when you're parallel to that
that's what it means that it's parallel
to the yz plane so therefore
to be parallel to the yz plane in three
dimensions what we really need is for
the x component to be zero so i'm going
to go ahead and write that straight away
that i'm going to have a 0 there that's
known and then it's the other two the y
and the z bits they're allowed to vary
right so therefore because they're
unknown i'm going to say well let's call
that a let's call that b and
i have no i vector since i am parallel
to the yz plane
so this is my new line
so it passes through
this part here passes through
the particular coordinates i need
two comma three comma one and then this
part here tells me i'm parallel
to the y z plane
oops not they
the
y z
plane
okay excellent now i'm ready to go i can
actually do that computation that i was
mentioning before about the dot product
right
when you take these two directions uh
two direction vectors here if they are
really perpendicular to each other then
when you do the dot product you should
find an answer of 0. so therefore let's
see what happens right i'm going to go
0 negative 1 3
dot
0 a b
that ought to equal 0
let's just move this onto a line
since
vectors are perpendicular like this is
the reason i'm not just pulling this out
of a hat
the reason i'm getting a zero dot
product is because of this
perpendicularity right and now it's just
a matter of just computing this right so
i'm going to go i'm going to you know
multiply my x components which is 0
multiply my y components multiply my
z components so i'm going to get minus a
plus three b
equals zero equals zero um so therefore
a
equals three b and you might say well
hold on mr we've got um you know
infinitely many solutions to this right
because a can take on any value and once
it takes on any value a different value
pops out for b right why is that so and
the answer is if you look at this well
the direction vector can be any multiple
of these so long as your your lambda is
appropriate right so therefore you know
say if this was 0 1 2
it would be exactly the same as another
direction vector 0 to 4 because heading
off in the same proportion right
in exactly the same way that you could
have um you know y equals 2x plus 5 and
you could also have 2y equals 4x plus
10. like you just multiplied it all by 2
it's still the same line so that's why
you get infinitely many solutions here
you just have to designate just pick a
number pick a convenient thing right so
if i say let
b
equal to one that will make a equal
three and that's convenient so let b
equal one that means a equals three and
that should do it right i can say
therefore my new line is going to be
equal to what was i on 2 3 1
2 3 1 plus lambda of
0
3
1
like so
that's all there is to it um i suppose i
could write that um in you know
component form but it's you know the
original line was given to us in column
form so i'm pretty satisfied with that
so please be mindful like the hard part
of this this is not a hard question to
compute you can see there's hardly any
working compared to some of the early
questions we've been looking at but it's
really the thinking that you needed to
employ